[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here so in
case you somehow missed it apple's wwdc
was this week and the stuff they
announced there has been making tech
headlines pretty much every day since
so typically when apple gets up on stage
they share something that they've been
you know working on behind the scenes
for a long time and they're finally able
to share it with the world they get on
stage and they share it and then there's
the sort of reaction from the internet
everyone's blogging tweeting making
their videos about it and then apple's
usually just like
zipped
nothing they never really reply that's
typically where the conversation ends
but not this year 2020 in many ways is a
little different so after the keynote
this year after their online-only
presentation i got to have a
conversation with the man you may
recognize from tons of facetime in the
keynote singer vp at apple craig
federighi we had a decently long chat on
the waveform podcast with a whole range
of topics from the behind the scenes of
how they made that two-hour keynote
movie basically to uh all the software
and the new stuff that they've announced
and you know it's not all roses and
flowers some of the stuff they announced
was pretty controversial too so luckily
enough i was recording video on my end
craig had some iphones set up recording
his end in apple park so if you want
more of the summary of the really long
list of things that they've announced
that are new you can go back and watch
my last two videos that go into that
stuff in lots of detail but this
this is the more rare conversation part
all right so point number one
default apps so you may remember one of
the new announcements in ios 14 was the
ability to newly change your default
mail or browser apps and the reaction to
that was at first largely very positive
including for me uh that's like a from a
very traditionally stubborn company from
like apple not something you would
expect
but then after like a day or two of
digestion the questions start coming up
well what about maps why not other
things too
here's what he had to say i did hear
that you were looking forward to using
alternatives
yeah yeah i mean there you go i love
everybody i love that extra layer i
think my my natural question to that is
okay it's only mail and browser is there
a reason
you didn't have full-on you know chaos
or or even just maps because i think
maps would have been nice to also be
able to set as a default you know
honestly uh
a great point i mean i think for us we
looked at what were the top things that
we'd been hearing people say they they
wanted to configure and there's
definitely uh those two that rose to the
top uh so um i'll certainly take take
the input about about maps as well it
was uh
this was this was just where we started
i think your point on on chaos is an
important one i mean obviously with with
ios we're
very careful about trying to keep we we
know how
uh platforms can sort of descend into
chaos and uh particularly when
um apps that you know might honestly not
even be browsers uh you know how to
decide they're gonna be a browser and
then
you know try to hook into being your
browser because maybe they could
redirect you to a different uh tracked
ad experience when you click on
something or bounce you into you know
who knows what and so
we are very careful about
um making sure that that experience that
we don't have people getting uh misled
or have their device gets
configured into a place where uh boy
they just don't even like uh like using
their their uh their phone anymore
because it's gotten so wonked up so uh
we we proceed cautiously on these things
for sure does that mean there will be uh
i assume well i maybe i shouldn't assume
that not every app can add that flag to
potentially be a default browser but
only certain approved ones yeah you're
exactly right so so we uh will have
criteria
for
the you have to be a general purpose
browser and they'll be i mean the ones
you would think of as using as your
browser will of course all all qualify
um but we don't want um a random game to
just claim like yeah i'm a browser you
know i'm willing to throw up a webkit
view now and then in in the middle of my
game experience i'm going to be your
browser
because we think that could could
readily be abused so we want real
general purpose mail apps and real
general purpose uh browsers to be able
to
present themselves to the user with this
functionality and and keep out all the
rest of the confusion gotcha so the
browser point i think is actually a
really good one something to sort of
think about a little bit if any app can
just become your browser when any link
comes up and then that app has different
policies on tracking and privacy
then it sort of goes against your own
policies on tracking and privacy now we
see this on android all the time and
it's actually more of a it feels like a
convenience and more customization
feature but in relay for reddit for
example if i click a link to read a
story it doesn't have to open chrome
there's a browser built into the app
here so it just opens that and that's
convenient but craig's response here is
basically that sometimes apple has to
take a stance against some of that
convenience in favor of maintaining
their own pretty strict privacy policy
makes sense then next up was siri so
siri got a bunch of improvements in ios
14 as well answers a bunch of new
questions now and it also is in this
compact new ui with a much smaller
animation i pointed out in my videos and
a lot of people also reacted that you
couldn't really interact with things
behind siri despite that smaller
animation siri also gets a new compact
ui both on the phone yeah and on the
ipad
but something we've noticed since using
it is it is a compact ui but you can't
interact with things underneath or
behind it
um is that intentional is that a
limitation what's what's that story no
no and in fact you know we tried it both
ways we we had uh
internally we had prototypes running
where uh you would scroll behind
uh the siri answers as you brought them
up and initially we thought that was
gonna be
uh really great and so we implemented it
that way and then what we found was that
for most of the interactions we were
having with siri
that that then created this kind of
extra heaviness to it because
if you just said wanted to check the
weather or look up a piece of
information and then you were ready to
move on
your
scroll gesture wasn't going to move on
the siri result was going to stick
around there so you always had this
additional step
of dismissing the result and we found
that to be
extra heavy and so uh you know we'll
continue to listen to what people have
to say through the beta period because
like i say i mean we've we actually have
it working both ways um but but our
feeling was that we wanted to achieve a
a great lightness not just visually but
in terms of you could dip into siri get
an answer and and move on uh quickly
without any kind of overhead in the
subsequent interaction so there's
there's definitely a real balance there
yeah i i felt that the experience was a
little different on the phone versus the
tablet you know on the phone it felt
like it made sense i'm not necessarily
reading or scrolling or doing things
behind siri very often but the tablet
with the bigger screen
to me felt like an opportunity to give
me a little more of like the the
multitasking feel that i talk about on
ipad yeah where you do feel like you
have a little more control over leaving
siri there while you do other things and
coming back to it so that might be
something to look into yeah did you have
a thought about what you how you would
have expected if you were to let's say
start you know you got your answer and
then you started scrolling and doing
other things on your ipad yeah at what
point you would expect siri to kind of
get itself out of the way or whether you
would have preferred to you know have it
hang out for you know minutes and then
you go over there and manually put it
away
yeah so i think because that animation
came in from the bottom and then the
answer came in from the top i almost
felt like it would be different behavior
on the phone but i almost felt like just
being able to swipe it out of the top
where it came from to disperse it uh
sort of like a notification even though
it isn't one
or bringing that siri animation from the
bottom corner and just swiping it down
out of where it appeared
um so that's again there's probably a
thousand ways to to also consider doing
it but i think that just because i'm
such an ipad multitasking
advocate i think that would be something
i'd be interested in all right so there
you go makes sense to me the one extra
step of dismissing siri is one extra
step they feel like they wanted to avoid
but also again i think it's important to
mention that these are
the videos i was making were about
developer betas and these are early
software that can continue to be changed
down the road he mentions they could
change it so if you do see that behavior
change maybe they've thought about it
more alright so then the big one mac os
big sur new visuals new rounded corners
new icons
i had to talk about it seeing all those
visual changes it got a very mixed
reaction online and i'll share some of
mine after but yeah there's a there's a
sort of an overarching theme of these
rounded corners and a new transparency
and a different sort of look to it can
you talk about that theme of mac os big
sur yeah well i think the the first
thing just to address the the 11.0
i mean we do feel that
between the the new design
and
the
the beginning of a new chapter with the
introduction of apple silicon i mean i
think this is this is just the beginning
i mean this is a this is a real renewal
of the platform in in many ways and so
we're really excited to to mark this
with uh
the next chapter the turning into the
next chapter with with uh with 11. um as
far as the the design goes
you know i think
it's a huge part of our
visual scenery of our lives at this
point and so what seems right is partly
what we're used to seeing on that screen
every day and when it changes
immediately there's all kinds of little
pattern recognizers in our brain that go
like hold on something's different
something i feel like after you use the
ui for and i've been living on it for
months
it feels natural it feels
um fresh and yet
clearly distinctly mac
and i love it and i think that it's
natural the first time you you see it
and of course the internet reacts on
like they see a single screen shot and
then let's start a tweet storm and then
let's pile on um
they don't they don't necessarily live
on it right and so um i will love to
hear the feedback of people as they've
if they've really made it their system
like they have the previous mac uis for
you know for weeks and and come back and
say how do you feel about it now
um i think the design team did amazing
work and i i find you know things like
rounding you know some of those choices
may seem arbitrary but in fact it's
extremely consistent throughout that
whole experience and i think it's really
organic you know straight edges like
this are like the process of human
manufacturing processes you know uh if
you look out in nature if you look at
our own faces
there's a lot of curves uh right and
natural curves and so i think there's
something really beautiful and organic
about the the look of the ui
uh
and uh i think the the use of the use of
materials is really great um the clarity
of some of the unified toolbars i think
is is just clean and fresh and really
deferential the content
and then of course i mean it's a big
step to change the icons of the mac
that's certainly a signature change
but what we found when we live on it is
we're all moving back and forth between
our iphone our ipad our mac and having
that
consistency and familiarity just takes a
level of of sort of mental mapping
energy out of the whole thing and it's
just it's relaxing it's comfortable it's
it's clear
uh and so you know we approach that
decision with a lot of a lot of debate
um but in the end we we tried it and it
just it just felt right and i think as
people use it they're going to come to
the same conclusion yeah those new icons
are not from ipad or iphone right
they're new they're totally new icon set
as far as like finder and
and spotify and final cut like all these
new apps on the mac
we did not create a spotify app we would
not make we would not make that step i
mean it might be fun to try but i don't
think we're allowed to do that right um
we
we did you're right so there's some mac
uh some icons like like finder exactly
where uh there's no analog and so we got
to imagine with the new shape and
aesthetic how how should should the mac
look and i think i i love what we came
up with there um then there are other
icons uh like say safari or messages
where
uh we took the ios icon and the typical
you know chiclet shape um but applied a
little bit of the traditional mac craft
to
uh
to it and i think that's been where
there's some of the controversy right
now where people are saying hold on i
know what that iphone icon looks like
and this one seems just a little
different something's tripping here and
going like this isn't quite right um
and you know that's that's natural and
understandable but we we did want to
pay homage to that history of great uh
craft and detailing that's been part of
uh the mac the history of mac icons and
so we kind of brought those those two
together and hopefully in the end uh
successfully i think this is all
a very eloquent way of saying
you'll get used to it
and i think that's that's kind of he's
got a good point you probably will
eventually get used to it after a while
but
the other thing is design is subjective
and sometimes there are designs that
even if you do get used to them you
still don't like them like for me an
example is on my phone i use waze for
navigation i don't use apple maps or
google maps that much anymore that's
because i like the feature set but every
time i open waze
i hate looking at it it's just it's ugly
it doesn't look good it's not clean or
elegant or flat or minimal or modern or
anything every time i open it i hate it
but i don't switch because it still has
the feature set i like
and i feel like apple knows that and
they also know people aren't going to
switch off from mac os because they
didn't really like the new icons people
complain about iphones all the time and
then what do they go out and buy the
next iphone so
he's got a point we'll get used to it
but also craig or anyone else at apple
who may stumble upon this video i talked
about the other icons and how i might
not like them and that's preference but
this battery icon in system preferences
i
you gotta fix this one i'm sorry there's
just there's no way this should make it
out of the beta please change this
battery icon all right i got i got a
couple fan questions as well i asked
i put it out on youtube we had some some
questions and we're going to have craig
on the podcast um first one
the ipad still does not have
a default weather and calculator app and
they want to know why
you know there's some things that we
we have not done because
we to do it we would want to do
something really distinctly
great in that space and uh i think it's
obviously easy to create a calculator
app uh but creating one that feels like
wow this is this is this is the greatest
ipad calculator app that it felt like i
think we we we want to do it when we can
do it really really well and and we we
honestly have just uh
uh
haven't gotten around to doing it great
so uh that day that day may come but uh
and you know whether it be easy enough
to scale up our additional our existing
weather uh app but we feel like what
would a great weather app for ipad be
like let's let's do that before we do it
and otherwise they're great options on
the app store i mean
there are thousands of options on the
app store in fact so very true i think
this one it resonates to me because one
of my favorite apps you guys just
acquired dark sky so it's no longer on
android so i'm like
this this ios weather app better turn
into this amazing thing so um i think i
think it may be time for an ipad weather
app that's just me i'm just saying all
right well and it could be could be time
for you to go iphone exclusive i think
that would be another another another
good move that's a big point of leverage
you make a great point
another question is uh there's a there's
a very small group of people out there
apparently that have an ipad
and want to use an apple watch but don't
have an iphone
um
is this a workflow you guys think about
or are there groups of people who
maybe that's too small of a group of
people to cater to but will there ever
be an ipad
apple watch
experience
we don't i mean i i get it i think i
think there's an interesting place where
apple watch can for many people take
that kind of the device that i need to
have with with having lte it can be that
device that gives you the degree of
connectiveness connectedness on the go
and then you've got your your ipad when
you want to um get deeper
and it's a sensible it's a sensible uh
point it is not one that we uh have
pursued yet um i mean i wouldn't rule it
out but
so i i get it i uh i love using my ipad
and i love using my apple watch so i
could i could understand that so there
you have it some interesting stuff some
some new information and some
clarifications on stuff that's already
been announced good conversation
material and again it's a much longer
fuller more detailed conversation over
on the waveform podcast so in case you
want more quarantined content or if you
haven't listened to my podcast yet feel
free to hit the link below the like
button to check it out um we've got
other guests on previous episodes too
but you can subscribe and listen to it
anywhere podcasts are but let me know
what you think in the comments section
below and we can continue the
conversation 2020 style
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one shout out
to expressvpn for sponsoring this video
so if you're like me and you feel like
you've watched nearly everything online
the number one thing you need is
expressvpn see streaming services like
netflix have different shows and movies
available in different countries which
means there are titles out there that
you didn't even know that you don't have
access to but expressvpn lets you change
your location which essentially unlocks
all these different shows and titles
that netflix and other streaming
services have so i've been using
expressvpn to watch star trek discovery
which is only available for netflix in
the uk but it's pretty easy you just
fire up the expressvpn app change the
location to the uk and then refresh
netflix or whatever service you're using
and that's it it's fast it works on a
computer or on my phone or even on the
tv so you can watch these new things on
the big screen look you've heard me talk
about vpns before and why they're so
important for online security and
privacy but expressvpn is the one i
trust because they explicitly do not
track any of your online activity and
they've even gone above and beyond to
engineer every single one of their vpn
servers to run only in ram which means
even if there was a bit of data tracked
which there isn't it would be gone with
a reboot so thanks to them being such a
good partner with the channel i'm giving
away three extra months of expressvpn
for free so if you want to take
advantage of this content boosting
vpn feel free to head over to
expressvpn.com
mkbhd so that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace